I guess we're done. it. No. Uh, what was that? Oh,
um, Oh, I told you this. I wanted to,
this chick came up to me when I was at the coffee bean. I was killing it.
I was drinking iced Americano, you know, always doing that. Yeah. So,
but sometimes I get three shots over ice, but at coffee bean,
they kind of do a good iced Americano. Now here's the thing.
This girl came up to me and she was like, Hey, I'm a,
I'm such a big fan. I'm so nervous. Okay.
But I'm such a big fan. And I just wanted to tell you that. And I said,
Oh my God, thank you so much. That's so sweet of you. She was very sweet.
I was all smiles. And I was like, that's amazing. And,
and she was like, uh, and she was like, uh, yeah,
I actually ran into you, uh,
a few months ago and you even held the door open for me.
And I always thought it was so sweet. So you're a really sweet guy, gentlemen.
Yeah. And I was like, ah, well, you know what? I was like, Hey,
I guess he caught me on a good day. Right. So she says,
Oh, I caught you on a good, okay. Like, Oh wow, cool walks away.
He goes back to her seat.
She's back at her seat and I'm drinking my in Marikana, you know?
And now it's half half done. And I think I'm waiting for my buddy to get there.
Yeah. And then I hear from over my shoulder at her seat,
I guess I caught you on a good day. Oh, she's like harping on it. And I say,
and I turn around and I say, yeah, yeah.
Or whatever, you know, I dunno. And she says, you're an
just like that. And I said,
uh, Oh, what?
And she says, I guess I cut you on a good day. I was like, yeah. You know, like,
you know, like I was just, I don't know. I literally I'm, I,
I pride myself in kind of always at least saying something that keeps the
conversation going, bro. I had no clue what to say.
And I just kind of turned around and went back to my iced Americano.
And I was like, Jesus Christ. Did she stay? Like,
she sat the whole time she was there the whole time. Yeah. She stayed.
She was like 10, 15 feet away from me.
I pride myself on like knowing what's happening when they're
insane. Yeah. I don't even have a, yeah, I know it's on that one.
I don't know either. I don't know either. Um, there is, uh,
th th that's a funny story as it is. Okay. Just because I, you know,
I didn't add anything to it. Just the fact that it happened was funny. Right.
A few things that I didn't say about that happening,
make it a way different story. Oh, this is
[inaudible] or at the end was like, Oh,
and guess what also there's no Harry Potter in the world where that happened.
So, um,
she said she had a really severe, like physical condition.
Like she had a, um, uh, a Walker and she was like,
so, so, so this is why here the door open. Now the scholars in that,
so I'm not that much of a gentleman. It wasn't even that good of a day.
It was just like, you,
can't not open a door for someone who maybe I don't remember. Right. Okay. So,
um, she probably could have got out herself. Didn't have to do it. No.
So I didn't have to do it, but, but maybe it's, you'd argue.
Maybe it's nicer than I did it. I don't know. Right, right, right. Yeah. Uh,
maybe I probably got up out of my seat to do it. I don't know.
I'm not trying to say I'm a good guy, but whatever I'm saying,
you're adding parts that you don't even remember now you're bragging about being
a nice guy too. Right. Aren't even maybe true. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you.
So I do that made it more confusing or less confusing.
I dunno, because I don't know. I was like, and this is now,
this is why maybe I'm a bad guy. I'm like, well, does she just not know?
Because is her, is her, does this get me in trouble?
But like, it's also her mind effected by this. Like,
is it not just the physical I'm? Sure. Yeah. Yeah. So maybe, maybe now I'm like,
maybe she doesn't know the saying because she definitely doesn't know the
saying, but that could be regardless of, of, uh, either way.
She's so demented to like, sit, I didn't when you texted me,
because you told me that I didn't tell you the part about the thing.
I didn't know the part that there was a gap between you telling her that and her
being an Sol favorite part of the story is imagining her stewing about that and
like unable to deduce that you meant. Yeah. Good things. Yeah. So innocuous,
do you think that because of her physical handicap that has nothing to do with
it? That's the thing, I didn't know. I think her physical handicap has not,
has nothing to do with it. Yeah. I mean, I don't think it may,
it may be does, but my sense is that, look, I'm always like
my interactions with people throughout the course of the day. Yeah.
I'm constantly thinking people are demented. Yeah.
Like, well, Bob Larson, demented people, but even non exorcists. Right.
demented. You know what I mean? They'll figure out ways to get offended.
They'll figure out ways to misconstrue what you're doing or just be really
rude for no reason at all.
And that's part of the reason I wanted to do my podcast because everything uses
me about everything everyone's always doing. Yeah. That is a great example.
So you should have her on the podcast. Yeah. Get her, get her in open dialogue.
I also adheres like the comedian in me, which is like so like that.
But I, and I didn't make this joke, but I thought about if I did make this joke,
it would be when she was came up to me, she was,
I'm so nervous. And I was like,
and this is such bad joke. But I was like, I was like.
And the fact that even thought it made me feel bad, but I was like,
I wonder if she wasn't as nervous if she would be shaking less.
You know what I mean? Yes. I do know what you're saying.
That the fact that I thought that I felt awful. Yeah. Don't feel bad though.
Yeah. Yeah. Because I actually thought, because actually thought I wonder,
because she was like, Oh my God, I'm shaking.
She was like doing you like so much. Yeah.
And you saying caught me on a good day. Yeah.
Made her go from being a Supreme mega fan to
calling you an. Yeah. To you. Yeah. True.
Yeah. That's the biggest leap. Yeah.
To go from loving you to think weird thing. Because like,
I felt bad for her. I wanted her to be okay. I wanted, I, you know,
there's a problem right. There shouldn't feel bad for anybody. Anybody. No,
I don't think so. I, you can feel it,
but like you can't put it out in the world. You know what I mean? I wasn't like,
Oh, okay. Well, you know, he did open a door for her though. Yeah. I know.
I don't know, man. I thought a whole thing.
Like I just like what the problem is, the problem is like,
then I started thinking about like the, the world we live in and like,
God forbid, like I said, what I just said on Twitter. Yeah. There'll be awful.
It wouldn't be funny. It's not funny that I thought that, but, but,
but as a comedian, you think of all these bad jokes and you sift them out.
Right. Then the difference between
like burying yourself on Twitter and not is just literally
typing the stuff and putting it in the world because everyone has those up
thought. Oh yeah, yeah. You know? Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
if everyone was always saying what was coming into their mind,
every single person would be, have to be in like a mental institution. Yeah.
But isn't that, but isn't that, but that makes me lose. That's crazy to me.
W which part of it like that, you can just think a thought yeah. That,
that everyone's thought this. Yeah. But if you write it on Twitter, you're,
you're done. Yeah. You're done. You're you're literally done.
We all think that if we wrote it on Twitter, we're done. Right,
right. Right. Especially as like a celebrity. Sure. Just done. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. We should just, we should just say a button. Well,
I think that, yeah, well, yeah. No, I think that, um,
it's I literally think that one day, like the Sony hack. Right.
Everything's just going to come out. Yeah. You've said that before,
like you're going to have the day where I want it to make a TV show about this.
And, um, I didn't, I didn't ever pitch it,
but I wanted it to be about like the day that that
happens.
Everybody's email and texts and
everything is just available because that day is going to happen. Yeah. I agree.
Yeah. And, and,
and then we're going to live in a very different yeah.
Because people like legitimately Barack Obama. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's, I mean, there's no way he hasn't texted, like, let me see your. Yeah.
Yeah. And, and guaranteed by Barack Obama has texted at least once.
Let me see your tickets. Yeah. Yeah. You know? Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. I mean,
that's going to have to change everyone's judgment of everyone else. Yeah.
For sure. You know, you're gonna have to like all, let me see your. Yeah.
Now folks, folks, let me see your in an orgy
with just a, uh, a button-down and a tie and a blazer and no pants.
I didn't have time to take the whole thing off book, Obama.
So worst joke. Even worse than the off-color joke that I didn't do. Right.
I mean, the things that you're talking about,
the things that we think about in conversation that just popped into our minds.
Yeah. I'll, they'll often be like violent for me. Um, yeah. Like with you,
I'll be like,
thinking about like ripping your throat out and it's all good, but bad breath,
but I don't do ever thought that about you by the way. And it's all good,
but okay. Well now I feel bad. Yeah. Even though I shouldn't, but like,
but it's probably, honestly, honestly,
it's probably because you're my younger brother and I'm your older brother
because you, well, it's not psychoanalyze. No, I'm not. Because I feel like I,
I,
there is a part of me where I feel like I would take care of you no matter what.
And that's because you're my younger brother, honestly,
you're making me feel so bad and it's all going. It's just like, no, no, no.
It's okay. Because you want to kill me because that's, that's a thing.
It's like a 14 brothers hat. They want to be the,
and I get it and it's not chill out though. I would let you know.
How bad do you feel? Definitely chill out though. But like, even like,
just like, if I'm like ordering a bagel, you know, like, like what if I just,
like, I want to like spit in this person's face, you know,
just like constant barrage of that. Barack Obama. Brazo mama
folks. I want to spit in your face. Yeah.
Why is he Southern when you do it folks? Why is he on a King of the Hill?
Listen, I don't want to spit in your face. Um, so, um,
Oh boy, it's a hot one out, huh?